[Music]
ecole alone or Keola because 11 no
Komachi in the languages life in the
language is dead I am talking Olga Meyer
I've been a professor of Hawaiian
language at the University for 35 years
and through our work with the Hawaiian
language newspaper archive we're
bringing new light to Hawaii's past by
digitizing translating and training
people to access over a century's worth
of untapped historical knowledge
Hawaiians have never really had easy
access to the insight of their own
people of the past
a Hawaiian Society was an oral Society
for a millennia and then with the coming
of Westerners there was a real interest
in written language within a generation
you have almost universal literacy in
Hawaiian compare that to America which
probably had 50% literacy at the time
they are running a very progressive
little kingdom that is respected around
the world 1834 the first newspaper
happens by the 1860s there's three four
and five papers at a time and by the
1870s there's ten newspapers in a
population that's only about 70,000
people that's a huge output by 1860 the
kingdom recognizes that change is
happening so fast population is
declining so fast
then there's letters and the papers
saying those of you who are
knowledgeable in almost any field please
write it down and put it here it'll be
safe generations from now we will need
and it was so true so they're able to
start writing down what had kept a
society alive and well on such a limited
resource base as an island over
centuries this is how farming works this
is how fishing works for Hawaiians as a
whole this is a history that simply
wasn't available for the last four
generations from the 1970s we have
what's called a Hawaiian Renaissance the
renewal of interest in cultural
practices is what built the language
community that open up this historical
cache of newspapers
125,000 pages of newspapers had been
published we know only about 75,000 of
those pages have been found in local
archives but all of the pages in hand
have been digitized and are accessible
40 years we get 25,000 people speak or
him and the other million don't we still
have to make this material accessible to
an audience that hasn't yet gotten there
this body of knowledge is not just for
Hawaiians this is a global resource so
the idea of sustainability is documented
there being able to see that is critical
for us today we don't have to make
things up we actually have an experience
base to look at
[Music]